So now that you've survived the bunny uprising, we're ready to
get to the main goal of this class, as far as building
the search engine. Our goal is to improve the results by finding
the web page instead of just returning a list of all the
web pages that match a query. As the web has grown, it's
become more and more important for search engines to do this ranking
well. That what really distinguished Google
from previous search engines was they
had a much smarter way of ranking pages that produced more useful
results, where the first one or two results in response
to a search query were often the very thing that
the user was searching for. So now we're ready to
start thinking about the problem of how to rank web
pages. Let's start by recapping how our search engine works.
So we started by building a crawler. And what the
crawler did, and this is what we did in units
one, two, and three, what the crawler did was follow all
the links in the web pages. Following those links, building up an index.
And the end result of the crawler, after units four
and five was we had an index. By the end
of unit five, it was a, a table where we could look up a key word,
and we would find the entry where that
key word might appear. And we'd follow, and we
could look through each of those entries to find the one
that matched, and that would match the key word that we
were looking for. And as it's value, it would have a
list of all the urls where that keyword appears. And the
order of those urls in that list was determined just by
how we added them to the crawl. Every time we encountered
new page, we indexed that page, and we added a url
for that keyword. So the one that's first in this list is
just the one that we happen to find first. So
say it's the c page. The one that's second would be
the one that we find next. And it's this page. So,
this doesn't tell us anything about which page is best. So
the order of the URLs in the list and what we
were getting as our output just depends on the order that
things happen to go in the crawl. When the web was
really small, which was quite a while ago now, this was
sort of okay. That there were only a few pages that
might match a given keyword, and you could look through them
all and decide which one you wanted. With the web today,
this doesn't work at all. There are thousands of pages that
match any interesting keyword. Maybe millions. Certainly many more than you
want to look through by hand. So the most important thing
that a good search engine does is to figure out how
to rank these pages so the one that's at the front of
the list is the one the user wants. So that's our goal for
the rest of this unit, to figure out how to rank pages. Before
we do this for web pages, we're going to do something very similar, but
perhaps easier to relate to. We're going to
talk about how we decide who's popular.